good solid episode has done that track
have no complaints
[Music]
especially for time travel episode the
third episode of strafe's new worlds was
pretty good
I actually quite enjoyed it
I enjoyed it mostly though because there
was no glare and silly errors
with time travel episodes
it's very very easy to fall into the
Trap of doing something that doesn't
make sense so something's not going to
be logical in there you know it's very
easy to step on your own toes when it
comes to time travel episodes we've seen
that in lots and lots of sci-fi over the
years
this episode avoids all of them
um obviously the woman kept turning up
and saving the day turned out to be the
Romulan
spoilers
but that was kind of obvious the second
again Kirk spoilers Kirk and sing add a
bit of a smooch I'm like uh Kirk's
wearing a red shirt under that hoodie
yeah man's a dead man he's he's gonna
die it's a shame he didn't die in you
know like a way that he was actually a
hero he was just stood there
and he just sort of went ah you're not
gonna shoot me bang hello he could have
gone for the gun or something no just
just stood there okay
um
how they missed the opportunity to say
the Kirk
was born above the Iowa and he wasn't
born on the you know the ship from the
JJ Abrams movie or something
got the I can't remember that but
I think that was a missed opportunity
but yeah
um and he should have said something
when he died as well that would have
been good not just like say goodbye to
Sam
you should have said something but
anyway
there's lots of bits in that thing that
you think has a missed opportunity but
to be honest no one cares the only thing
in the whole episode I thought no
was the cat fight and then they sort of
sing in that room in the chick had a bit
of a fight I was just like it was it
wasn't very well choreographed and was a
bit slapped together and
um when we had the fight scene that went
on way too long in the first episode but
it was actually really really put
together very well but it turns out the
doctors actually
a martial artist which nobody knew about
until the police go apparently but um
that was that was actually really well
choreographed even though it was way too
long that fight was just
it's just that they could have done
without it
um
but but yeah I generally speaking not a
bad
episode of Star Trek strange new world
seems to be getting back on track
one thing
is Anson Mount actually on strike at the
moment because he is barely appearing in
this series of strangely world so far
and considering he's my favorite part of
stationary worlds
that's a little disappointing so far but
hey maybe they're just saving him up for
the rest
but hey guys I'd love to know what you
think get in the comments what do you
think of this episode of strange new
worlds just doing a very quick video
reaction
um not going to go into too much but I'd
love to know what you thought foreign
[Music]